so
that was a big prologue but i think it
was worth it let's now start to tackle
this question bit by bit and we are of
course going to have to start at the top
this is part a and what they do is they
introduce to us two particular integrals
that have this kind of variability
within them based on the power of this
cos x function that's being raised to
well you can see 2m in each case um and
the difference between the two is that
you've got this x squared term in the
integrand for bn but aside from that
they're otherwise identical it's a
definite integral we're going from
naught to pi on two that's going to be
important later on
and then i already signaled they've got
this cos term in there right
we're limiting n to being an integer and
they say right out the gate note that a
n is greater than zero and b n is
greater than zero now we're going to
sort of appeal to this fact later on but
i just want to explain why this is
obviously the case let's have a think
about a n first okay so you've got again
definite integral of this cos function
raised to a power and you're going from
naught to pi on two now think about this
for a brief moment
what does cos look like from naught to
pi on two well if i draw the um quickest
and dirtiest of quick and dirty sketches
right we know that the cos function
it will start from up the top and then
we'll sort of dip down like this value
and it'll come up to the end there at
two pi that's the whole domain there
right but the only part that we're
interested in is the naught to pi on 2
section that's the i guess you might
call it the first quadrant that's this
bit right here right because as soon as
you hit that intercept that's pi on 2
and this here the lower bound is 0. now
thinking about this carefully right what
we've got here
is the integral from 0 to pi on 2
but we kind of bounded in here from
naught to pi on 2 which is all positive
and then we raise that to some integer
power to we
power 2 power 4 power 6. they're all
even there because n has to be an
integer and then we're doubling that
right
so when you have a look at this thing
here when you have a look at the
function because it stays between naught
and one it's always positive right no
matter how many times you raise that
function or any value of that function
within that specific domain right there
from node to pi on two you're always
taking a value that is either positive
or zero right so this area will change
as you raise cos x to higher and higher
powers but it will never go beneath the
axis you're raising it it's a positive
thing and you're raising it to positive
powers right so therefore is it easy
yeah that's right positive powers i keep
moving around let's just zoom out a
little bit
these positive powers here mean you're
going to have an integral that's greater
than or equal
greater than zero in fact because you
always have non-zero parts and you can
apply very similar logic to bn right and
that x squared their term that that x
squared term there is going to be
similar um i won't put it on the same
graph because my scale will be all off
but we know what x squared looks like
it's going to be a
parabola like so
and from naught to pi on two again we
would say oh you know you go some you
know length up the graph you get to pi
on two right there and when you draw
that boundary again you're looking at an
area that is completely uh positive or
above the axis and then you square it or
you raise the power of actually it's
just squared because it's not having
that n in there so again a positive
thing that you're multiplying by the
integrand and that's why because an
integral can be interpreted as an area
under the curve
and that is why you're always going to
get these two integrals for whatever
value of n you take they'll be positive
okay
all right so i'm just pointing that out
because they tell you this so you don't
have to reason through it but i hope you
can see why like one of the great things
about mathematics is that to some extent
we deliberately designed the course to
do this you never have to accept what
someone just says you can actually
reason through it and understand the
logic
all right
so now knowing that
let's tackle part a show that
n a n equals and then you've got a
reduction formula or a recurrence
relation okay now essentially you know
as is often the case it's going to be
most helpful to tackle this via
integration by parts we've seen before
this is not the only way to make our
occurrence relation but it's pretty
straightforward in this case so we just
need to
set up our problem and then carefully
choose what our u and our dv will be
all right so let me begin by saying you
know reminder that a n equals we're
going from naught to pi on 2
and then here comes the integrand
cos to the power of 2n x
dx okay now if that's a n you can see in
the result that i'm required to prove
there's a n minus 1. i always find it
helpful to state what a n minus 1 is so
that i kind of know what i'm working
toward right and that helps me to choose
my u and my dv
so what does this imply about a n minus
one well let's just sift out the parts
that are independent of n first so our
boundaries are not going to change
they're naught and pi on two and they're
going to stay the same all the way
through the question you're going to
write it many dozens of times and then
you've got the n up there in the index
right so when you put in n minus 1
you're multiplying that by 2 you're
doubling it right so therefore you're
going to get cos of 2 n minus 2 because
you double the 1 as well
and that's of x with respect to x okay
so as i mentioned from here i now want
to choose a u and a d v
that's appropriate to allow me to uh get
from you know you can see the a n
expression over here and there needs to
be an a and minus one appearing on the
right hand side okay so what's a helpful
way to break this up now i would say if
you just choose um you know
you break this up into some break this
up rather into some arbitrary form you
may not land on this what i want is uh
thinking about something that i could
differentiate or integrate that would
lead me to this term in here okay now
because the power is lower this is 2n
minus 2.
it seems to me reasonably clear that i
should break this up this product up
into a way such that i can see one of
them should be the u so that i can
differentiate it and it will land me
here right well if this is 2 n minus 2
the term that will differentiate into
this will have a 2n minus 1 power right
so i can break that apart into here i
can see there's a 2n minus 1 hiding in
there as long as i just pull out one of
the cosines right so let's go ahead and
do that you can see i'm going to write
from naught to pi on 2
i'm going to separate out 1 cos x term
like so
and then i'm going to leave that with
cos of 2 n minus 1
x dx okay are you following so far so if
i take this term here and i define that
as u then when you differentiate that
you're going to land here
in this term which has the n uh the two
n minus two power that i was searching
for okay
all right so you've got that in mind
let's uh let's just do the integration
by parts now and i'll just push it off
to one side
as mentioned i'm going to let u equal
cos of 2 n
to the power of 2 n minus 1 x and that's
going to imply that d u
on dx is going to be all right let's
have a go here
differentiate the inside and then the
outside so that's going to give me
i've got cos x is the inside function
because it's it's cos x raised to that
power so its derivative is going to be
negative sine x
there's the inside now let's do the
outside you've got that power of 2n
minus 1. so i'll bring that out the
front let's chuck some brackets in there
and then i reduce the power by 1. so
it's going to be 2 n minus 2
and then that's of x so 6s you can see
there's that uh cos the 2n minus 2 x
that i was looking for
so if that's u and d u that means i've
now got to work out um v and dv of
course i'll work out in reverse order
right so i'll just chuck this derivative
over here on the right hand side
underneath dv on dx i'm just saying
that's going to be cos x happy times and
what that implies
is clearly that when you integrate up
you're going to have just regular old
sign and just double check you're like
yes differentiate this to get that happy
times
all right so i'm going to keep my
line of working here so let's just show
that that's our that's connected right
there
and i'm going to bring in the
integration by part so it's going to be
that definite integral part uv minus the
integral of v to u right right so let's
have a go
here comes the uv and because i've got
boundaries naught to pi on 2 this is
going to be evaluated so u v is going to
be sine x
cos of 2 n minus 1 x and i mean i wrote
them in reverse order but that's usually
just because you know this big messy
term here i like to keep it to one side
so that's going to be integrated from
lower bound to upper bound all right
happy times we'll return back to that
later let's not overload our working
memory let's go on to the rest of that
line so i'm going to subtract integral
again from naught to pi onto of v d u
okay so have a look here
here's v here's d u um you can
immediately see you've got these sine x
terms here that are going to combine
right so therefore i'm going to get a
sine squared x and just watch out for
the minus sign that's also here because
it's going to be a double negative in a
second yeah all right so here we go i'm
going to get minus of sine squared x
hanging out the front and then
everything else from d on dx sort of uh
comes along for the ride so i'm just
going to bring that along
be exceptionally lazy there there's the
rest of d u
and i'm going to have a dx hanging on
the end there okay so far so good
all right now let's look closely at this
it looks awful but stay with it because
they've given us these nice boundaries
naught and pi on two things are going to
simplify out really nicely for example
let's just think about that lower
boundary right when x equals zero if you
look closely at this first term in the
product when x equals zero sine x is
zero right so i'm going to write there
sine zero equals zero so when you
evaluate a lower boundary it doesn't
matter what the cos term over here is
equal to it'll be zero times whatever
right so when you substitute the lower
boundary in it's gone
same deal happens when you look at the
upper boundary but because of the other
term right this cos x term here i mean
we just drew the graph very briefly when
you put in pi on 2 cos of pi on 2 is 0
you're raising it to some power 2 n
minus 1 but 0 to the power of anything
is going to give you um that that zero
term there except for you know widow
powers that we don't need to worry about
n's an integer so this is well behaved
okay so therefore we can say cos of pi
on 2 that's going to give you a 0 term
so i'm going to write that in like so
so what that means is in summary this
definite integral here lower boundary
upper boundary just gives you a whole
lot of zeros okay so great
what else can we work with well you can
see there's a minus sign here minus sign
here we already flagged that before so
they're going to cancel out and then
when you have a look further down you've
got this sine squared term okay now it's
a conspicuous it kind of sticks out like
a sore thumb right because when you have
a look at
a n and a n minus 1 of course it's all
just in terms of cosine so i need to get
rid of this sine squared term somehow
thankfully all the way back from advance
we know we can just use the pythagorean
identity for that okay so hold on to
your hats let's get on to the next line
now i've thought about enough let's do
the evaluation
that definite integral stuff turned into
zero
those two negatives become a positive
and then we're going to go from nor to
pi on 2
and instead of writing that sine squared
x term here's where i'm going to
substitute in
1 minus cos squared okay there we go
and then like we had before everything
here comes along for the ride
okay happy times and uh when i have a
look at this you're like okay where am i
going here like i've done my integration
by parts but what i need to try and do
is get this a n more closely related to
a n minus one so i need to find where
this a and minus one this integral i
need to find where it is hiding inside
of my working okay now you can see
there's the cos two n minus two x that
i'm looking for so i just kind of need
to tease apart the algebra here a teeny
little bit okay
how do i do that well
you've got this 2n minus 1 which is just
a constant coefficient so i might as
well bring that outside of the integral
altogether so 2n minus 1 hanging out the
front there
from naught to pi on 2 and now what i'm
going to have to do to get the a n minus
1 term i'm going to have to expand this
right and you'll see it's also going to
give us some
a n terms as well so have a look when
you multiply through first here cos a
minus 2 x times one well you just get
cos of two n minus two
x and then when you put together these
two terms here let me just underline
that
this term and this term
this should look familiar right the
indices are going to perfectly fit
together so you're going to get
minus just watch out for that it's cos
of 2n
x
that's how those combine so you can see
here and i'm going to put in on the left
hand side now a n you can see this is
going to give you the a n minus 2. this
is going to give you the sorry the a
minus 1 i should say this is going to
give you the a n you just need to have
this 2n minus 1 hanging out the front
here ok and then i just need to collect
like terms with that a n and sort of
make the appropriate subject okay
all right so what do we get i've got an
a n on the left hand side
2 and -1 and once you evaluate you get
rid of those integrals you're going to
have let's get the colors right here if
we call this one
this one here is blue and i've already
got the other one as red this is going
to be the a n minus 1 term and then
this is going to be minus a
n okay following so far so at this point
um your calculus is well and truly done
and we just need to do some algebra okay
i'm going to as i mentioned before
collect the am terms on the left hand
side so that's going to give me let's
have a look here
how many ans are going to be there the
first one is already there on the left
hand side and then you're going to
careful there because there's a negative
i'm going to add 2 n minus 1 a n's to
both sides and that leaves you with 2 n
minus 1 a n minus ones on the right hand
side okay yeah there's a lot of algebra
in this all right have a look on the
left hand side there um you can see this
a n and this minus a n they're just
gonna go aren't they so that a n and
that minus 1 a n are going to cancel
and that leaves you with 2 n a n over
there on the left hand side
nothing has changed on the right hand
side so far
and then you briefly have a look back
you're like what was i supposed to prove
again i've got
this n a n on the left hand side so
that's a little interesting usually we
just make a n the subject but we leave
that in there and you can see oh look
that 2 is going to appear on the
denominator so i'm going to write that
like so
n a n equals two n minus one we divided
by two and then a n minus one as
required
[Applause]
okay fantastic well done congratulations
after an entire page of working you did
part a